Elif - welcome, it's so good to see you here
in London.
In a couple of months we'll meet again in
Amsterdam, as you are one of the speakers
for our conference 'What Will Save the World'.
Would you please be so kind to introduce yourself
to the Dutch audience?
You're a cosmopolitan, you're a novelist;
maybe you can tell us a little bit about yourself.
With pleasure.
I'm a writer, a novelist, a storyteller.
That's how I connect with the world, through
stories and through imagination.
That said, I also have an academic background,
an interdisciplinary background.
I was educated in international relations,
then I have done a Master's degree in women's
studies and then a PhD in political science.
I have always kept my connection with academia
throughout the years.
I'm also a public speaker and commentator
on various issues that I think are important
in the world today, so I do write for various
publications around the world.
To me, all of that is in harmony, but at the
same time there may be a gap,
because by nature I am an introvert.
As a writer, my job is based on solitude.
But I also have this other side that likes
to engage in public debates and likes to think
about the issues that matter today.
One of the gifts of being a writer is the
power of imagination, and you have a huge
power of imagination, as everybody who has
read your books knows.
But when you look at today's world as a writer,
then what is it that you see?
I see lots of signs that I find quite alarming.
Maybe I am a Gramscian in that regard, I always
share this pessimism of the intellect and
the optimism of the will, of the heart.
So I'm half pessimistic, half optimistic.
I am half pessimistic because, when I look
at the signs today, I see a very strong trend
back to what I call tribalism, back to nation
states, nationalism, religiosity - all those
divisive forces that many intellectuals in
the 1940s and '50s thought were going to disappear,
gradually.
That did not happen.
In fact the opposite happened; they made a
very strong comeback.
Religion is a major factor today, nationalism
indeed so, but also this tribalism that is
dividing humanity on the basis of imaginary
categories.
I am half optimistic when I look at the people,
global souls, I am a big believer in cosmopolitanism.
I'm a big believer in the truth that, in this
world, if we're ever going to learn anything,
we will learn it from people who are different
from us.
I have nothing to learn from someone who is
exactly like me, who thinks exactly like me,
but someone who is different will challenge
me, and perhaps I'll challenge him too.
So that diversity, that cosmopolitanism that
we are belittling today is something that
we need to renew.
I also believe in the power of humanism, in
the role of empathy on which the art of storytelling
is very much based.
But then the question is, and we will of course
discuss it at length at the conference:
the big question is, what happened?
After World War 2 we built our international
institutions like the United Nations.
We have wonderful NGOs like Human Rights Watch,
Amnesty International.
We became more prosperous, there's a huge
development in technology and science.
Then the fall of the Berlin wall; there was
a huge sense of optimism in the early '90s.
So how come, do you think, that we now have
this backward tendency?
There was indeed a huge tide of optimism in
the sense that many smart intellectuals thought
that, thanks to globalization, we were all
going to become a big global village, and
everybody would have primarily economic and
social ties, and that would help transcend
national and nationalistic boundaries.
It did not happen in that way.
I think we need to bear in mind that, when
we think about time, we tend to think that
time always goes in a linear direction.
But we have seen that time does not always
go forward: sometimes it draws circles,
it can move backwards.
In other words, what I'm trying to say is
that if we learn nothing from the mistakes
of the past, we are bound to make those mistakes
again and again.
That is what is so sad, how memory is lost.
And I'm not talking about the very long-term
memory of centuries, I'm talking about recent
political memory.
Even with regards to Europe, the EU: how it
was established, how the journey began.
Very few people today are talking about the
beginning, that spirit that initiated everything.
So we tend to take things for granted very
easily.
And I find myself in this a bit ironic situation,
to tell you the truth, because, coming from
Turkey, a country that's on the fringes of
Europe, and I live in the UK, I find myself
defending more passionately what I regard
as European values.
For me, the EU is not primarily a financial
project or an economic project; it is primarily
about values, which mean a lot to me.
By those values I mean freedom of speech,
the separation of powers, rule of law,
definitely women's rights, LGBT rights, minority rights
and many other human rights that all together
make sense.
So I do not take these values for granted,
because I do know that societies can lose
them.
Neither do I take cosmopolitanism for granted,
because I come from a country that has lost
its cosmopolitan heritage.
And I think that by losing that, Turkey lost
a lot.